Tach zusammen, Jack Pop hier.
Willkommen zurück zum Reality-Check von Superhelden.
Mein liebster Physik-Experte Henry nimmt uns
heute ins X-Men-Universum mit.
Hey Hendrik .. Moin Jack!
Heute geht es um Mystique, die ist eine Mutantin
und kann was ziemlich cooles.
Sie ist eine Gestaltenwandlerin und kann jede
beliebige Personen imitieren.
Ob das funktionieren kann, in echt, das spielen
wir heute durch.
Und wie geht das am besten?
Mit Tieren!
Los geht’s!
Tiere sind Meister der Tarnung.
Die können ihr Aussehen anpassen, um zu überleben
und Mystique macht das auch.
Henry.
Du hast Dich im Tierreich umgesehen und mal
geschaut, welche Physik-Tricks das wären
die Mystique da drauf hat.
Genau, also grundsätzlich unterscheidet man
erst mal bei der Tarnung von Lebewesen in
zwei verschiedene Arten; das ist die Mimikry
und Mimese.
Mimese bedeutet folgendes: Das ist eine evolutionäre
Anpassung vom Aussehen des Lebewesens, hin
dazu, dass es eben in der Umgebung verschwindet.
Dass es sich eben an den an die Umgebung anpasst.
Beispielsweise heißen Insekten so: das wandelnde
Blatt.
Also das ist so gut getarnt, dass es wie ein
wandelndes, sich bewegendes Blatt aussieht.
Ganz genau.
Mimikry bedeutet, dass das Aussehen des Tieres
sich dahin entwickelt hat, dass es eben Pflanzen
oder Tiere imitiert.
Das bedeutet zum Beispiel bei der Schwebfliege,
dass die aussieht wie eine Wespe aber die
ist eigentlich eine ganz harmlose Fliege.
Aber die täuscht damit ihre Fressfeinde und
sagt: „Hier Achtung, ich bin vielleicht
gefährlich.“
Okay.
Aber Mystique hat ja jetzt keine Evolution
hinter sich, die macht das einfach so.
Also so eine Art „Live-Mimikry“.
Und das gibt es im Tierreich ja auch.
Genau und zwar auf eine ziemlich coole und
beeindruckende Art und Weise bei Oktopussen.
Die machen sich nämlich ziemlich clever die
Physik zunutze.
Oktopusse haben unter ihrer Haut sogenannte
Chromatophore, das sind spezielle Pigmentzellen,
und in diesen Zellen sind so kleine, mit Farbe
gefüllte Ballons drin.
Das haben wir mal für euch vorbereitet und
mitgebracht.
Also hier ist ein Ballon mit Lebensmittelfarbe
und sowas ist in den Zellen drin.
Ganz genau.
Und zusätzlich sind da auch noch kleine Muskeln
dran und diese Muskeln können sich jetzt
anspannen und entspannen und den kleinen Ballon
größer machen.
Dann ist er eben besser sichtbar.
Und das können wir Euch auch mal zeigen.
Also wenn wir jetzt den hier nehmen und auseinander
ziehen, dann wird die Farbe bisschen heller.
Aber auch die Fläche der Farbe wird größer
und man sieht sie dadurch besser.
Noch beeindruckender sieht das natürlich
in echt aus.
Wir haben euch hier mal ein Video mitgebracht,
wo man diese Farbänderung in der Tintenfischhaut
sehen kann.
Genau das geht sogar noch weiter und zwar
liegen darunter noch zwei andere Zellschichten,
die eine Schicht besteht aus weißen Hautzellen,
das wirkt wie eine Leinwand als Hintergrund.
Darüber liegt noch eine Schicht aus reflektierenden
Zellen, die reflektiert bestimmte Anteile
des Lichts, also Blau, Grün, Silber oder
Gold beispielsweise.
Also wie ein Spezialfilter?
Ganz genau.
Okay, dann ist das ja quasi eine Farbmischung
wie bei einem Display oder bei einem Fernseher…
Ganz genau.
Das heißt additive Farbmischung.
Das bedeutet, von weit weg betrachtet ergibt
die Kombination aus verschiedenen Farben eben
eine neue Farbe.
Das kennt man zum Beispiel vom Fernseher.
Da wird Rot, Grün und Blau zu verschiedensten
Farben zusammengemischt.
Das heißt aber auch wenn das jetzt so mischen,
die müssen ziemlich gute Augen haben und
die Umgebung wahrnehmen.
Genau.
Ihr Gehirn macht nämlich folgendes: Das nimmt
den optischen Eindruck von den Augen und gibt
Anweisungen an die Chromatophoren, welche
Chromatophoren sich jetzt ausdehnen sollen
und welche nicht, um eben genau das Muster
und die Farbe vom Untergrund anzunehmen.
Das klingt total gut und ist ja auch das,
was Mystique machen kann.
Sie könnte, wenn sie diese Art von Zellen
hat, also tatsächlich alles Mögliche imitieren.
Vom Hautton zu Sommersprossen, Geburtsmalen
und wahrscheinlich sogar Tätowierungen.
Das wäre also durchaus möglich.
True story.
Oktopusse haben aber noch etwas anderes drauf.
Die können nämlich ihre Textur verändern
und das macht Mystique ja auch.
Also die verwandelt sich und hat dann plötzlich
andere Sachen an oder imitiert da irgendwie
Material.
Wie funktioniert das?
Das machen die Oktopusse über ein sehr feines
Muskel-Netzwerk unter ihrer Haut.
Und zwar funktioniert ein bisschen wie unsere
Zunge.
Unsere Zunge ist ein Muskel der Muskeln bewegt.
Ganz im Gegensatz zu unserem Arm beispielsweise;
da bewegen die Muskeln die Knochen über so
Hebelwirkungen.
Und diese Muskeln bestehen zum großen Teil
aus Wasser und Wasser ist inkompressibel.
Wir haben Euch ein kleines Modell mitgebracht.
Also dass ist ein Ballon gefüllt mit Wasser.
Der stellt jetzt einen ganz, ganz kleinen
Teil dieses Muskelgeflechts dar.
Ganz genau.
Inkompressibel bedeutet, egal wie viel Kraft
ich jetzt auf einen Teil des Wassers ausübe,
dass das Volumen insgesamt konstant bleibt.
Das bedeutet, wenn ich jetzt einen Teil zusammendrücke,
dann dehnt sich der andere Teil dieses Muskels
um denselben Betrag aus.
Und so kann über Veränderungen dieses Netzwerks
eben eine ganz andere Textur erzeugt werden.
Und da haben wir Euch auch noch mal ein Video
mitgebracht, indem man das live an Oktopus-Haut
sieht und das sieht so aus: Durch diese Muskelkontraktionen
stülpt sich da was raus und dadurch entstehen
Strukturen und Texturen.
Damit könnte Mystique also tatsächlich verschiedene
Materialien, Leder, Stoff, zumindest nachahmen.
Auf jeden Fall.
Und an der Universität Chicago arbeiten Biologen
und Ingenieure genau daran.
Die nehmen sich den Tintenfisch oder den Oktopus
als Vorbild und bauen ein 3D-Material, was
man programmieren kann dann seine Oberfläche
entsprechend dieser Programmierung ändert.
Er ist ja irre!
Das heißt, wir hätten dann eine Art Morphsuit,
also einen Anzug, mit dem wir selbst zu Mystique
werden können.
Mega!
Kurz und knackig haben wir das heut auf den
Punkt gebracht.
Es liegt ja auch auf der Hand, die Natur macht's
vor Mystique kann es nachmachen.
Wenn sie diese Art von Zellen hat, dann ist
das recht plausibel.
Auf jeden Fall und sie ist ja eine Mutantin.
Also, geht!
Wenn ihr noch Vorschläge habt, welche Superheldin,
welchen Superhelden wir mal für Euch durchspielen
sollen, dann schreibt es bitte in die Kommentare.
Gerne auch, wie diese Folge fandet.
Henry, wir kommen gern wieder nach Jena.
Schön, dass wir da sein konnten.
Danke auch.
Wir sehen uns nächste Woche wieder.
Bis dahin!